first up we got an old hair trend that
might be a
pop him back up you heard me writers at
allure
want to bring the poof back of the early
2000s
i mean here check out some poofs from
yesteryear
paris beyonce lindsay
and then you've got a jessica alba mary
kate a reese
and i was a [ __ ] yes you were oh yeah
so will you bring the poof back i would
you know what i have to say
actually the poof is extremely
flattering to the face
yeah um there's a reason that women do
it is because it's like an instant
facelift
it's very elongating very flattering and
we've actually got a special guest on
zoom joining us
she's rocked a poof you've also seen her
in movies like 22 jump street
and she's fantastic on that wonderful
show greek
she's on the carmichael show and now
she's in the upcoming stars series
run the world take a look at this ola's
mother wants branzino for the fish
entree
i love branzino uh no you don't you
think you love branzino because the
chefs always serve it as a special and
people who don't know better let other
people dictate to them what's actually
special in life
and because waiters are always referring
to it as a
european sea bass people get distracted
by the fact that in terms of taste
and flavor it's just glorified tilapia
amber stevens west thank you for coming
to the show
who are you guys great oh you so much
for coming
so we we got to know amber are you pro
poof you know
like drew was saying like the poof can
be very flattering but i feel like
most women were doing it just here and
then
leaving the rest of the hair down and
that was not a good look and i feel like
the reason we all started doing that was
because we all had bad bangs and we just
needed to clip them back
i mean that's certainly not wrong um
okay
tell us about run the world it's four
girlfriends in harlem
i'm getting strong sex in the city vibes
there's a lot to be compared i mean it's
for women we're in new york
but you know it's more for like a new
generation
sex in the city was for its time and it
was about
dating and our show is more for like the
modern woman and we're not so focused on
like how to get a man and how to keep a
man we're
you know more about like our girlfriend
and our friendship and sisterhood and
you know picking each other up when we
fall and making fun of each other and
you know growing well i'll be tuning in
consider me sold yeah i'm in exactly way
to pitch it
okay amber are you ready to hit some
headlines with us
let's do it let's do it rossi take it
away all right we've got a story about
the joys of air travel with
babies have you ever been on a plane and
someone walking in with like a newborn
oh yeah and i know what they felt
because normally i would stare and be
like oh
no but then and then i was the one with
the baby
yeah uh well uh now uh
you amber you're you're made in a big
announcement right
i've got a second child on the way yes
congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
well then you're going to relate to this
whether you've you know been that person
who like oh no a baby on a plane or
you've been the person bringing a baby
on the plane this story from upworthy
check it out it's a tick tock posted by
a mom named johnna gleason
she and her husband they were on the
plane with their baby and they were
struggling
and you know it was seventh month old
was having a full down
melt down on the plane but then a
stranger across the aisle
rather than like being mad offered to
hold the baby
so they handed the baby over and just
like that
instantly calm what do you think about
this have you ever had that moment where
your baby was crying and a stranger's
the only one that can calm down
i haven't yet been in that situation but
i have certainly been on the plane with
a crying baby and felt
really sorry for the parents that are
having to deal with it i mean before you
have kids it's very easy to eye roll and
be like oh i'm on a plane with a baby
but i think now when you have a kid and
you really know like how
hard it's going to be you have a lot of
compassion for someone going through
that
i mean i've been on the plane where the
flight attendants just jump in and they
hold the baby and
you know it takes a village it really
does it does and i
would allow anyone to just hold my baby
for a second if she was freaking out of
course
please help me yeah yeah let's all try
to be more like that woman
exactly deal all right well i want both
of your takes on this one
a writer at purewow says that she and
her husband improved their connection
and even cut down on fights by using the
half glass of wine technique
the idea came from her therapist and
it's simple schedule a half glass of
wine with your partner every night and
when you sit down to play catch-up
the only rule is that you can't talk
logistics or to do is
just focus on each other okay amber
you're married to
actor andrew west so what do you
think of this and ross i want to know
what you and wellington are going to
think amber you first
i'm this is brilliant i think it's a
great idea this is how we got
through the pandemic and i can't wait to
do it again
when this person gets out of my body
[Laughter]
i love that i think it's so important to
make that time to connect
my only problem with this half glass of
wine challenge not enough
she can be a half bottle of wine hello i
totally agree
yeah i mean it is though like so
important to sit across from each other
and to catch up on your day not to talk
about the bills
or the schedule or something but like
you know how do you feel today what
happened
to just connect purposefully i think
having those rules about just like
not talking about triggers
um things that trigger the only problem
is is if you get to that
whole bottle of wine and then you start
talking of triggers that's a whole other
article
yeah ross your story yeah but yeah
but it can also be a whole lot of fun if
you finish that bottle of wine too
as long as you don't talk about the
trigger yeah leave the triggers at home
okay next we're going to expand our
vocabulary i love this we're going to
learn
a brand new word it is the latest term
that all the youngins all the kids are
using on the internet and we
are cool the new york times reports the
word
chugi it means something out of style or
off trend
or not cool anymore it can be applied to
a person or a thing no drew you are not
chugging am i i hope i'm not chewing
you're cool but it could be a person or
a thing um
it's it's like in the eye of the
beholder so for example some of the
things that have been deemed chooky
um we have a chooky mood board they say
frappuccinos are
choogy they're kind of done uh the uh
the pool flamingo floaty
oh that was all over instagram a couple
years ago apparently it's
chugi uh uh oh drew they say they say
uggs are choogy don't you even touch
my uggs i will stick one of those uggs
where the you know
never mind i have to agree with you uggs
are not chewy so uh but we are not yogi
no i'm not chewy i'm refused
i refuse to be yeah but i'm gonna try to
start saying it trying to make it happen
well amber stephens west i am so
grateful that you
came here with your mad style your
gorgeous head to toe look and your
fabulous new show
run the world which premieres may 16th
on stars i think it's gonna be a smash
hit
you